economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón nuevamente con
nosotros en el estudio Daniela vamos a
empezar por Colombia porque la reforma
tributaria impulsada por el gobierno del
presidente Gustavo Petro llanto en su
recta final Sí señora Raúl El miércoles
fue aprobada por la plenaria del senado
y este jueves continúa la discusión en
la cámara de representantes después
pasaría a conciliación de las dos
cámaras antes de ir finalmente a sanción
presidencial con esta reforma el
presidente Gustavo Petro Busca un
recaudo adicional de unos 4.000 millones
de dólares el próximo año en los más
recientes cambios que han hecho los
legisladores respecto del proyecto
original uno de los más polémicos es la
eliminación de un artículo que buscaba
cobrar impuestos a las iglesias así como
de otro que pretendía incluir el pan
Entre los alimentos Ultra procesados que
van a ser sujetos a tributación tampoco
se grabarán sus dimensiones altas como
se tenía previsto en general para hacer
un resumen este proyecto se basa en un
mayor recaudo de impuestos a personas
naturales de altos ingresos también a la
reducción de beneficios Fiscales para
empresas la tributación a las bebidas
azucaradas y Ultra procesadas y
finalmente una lucha frontal contra la
evasión entre otros en Chile promueve su
propia reforma Dani Sí señor presidente
Gabriel Boris anunció el miércoles su
prometida reforma de pensiones entre
otros crea un gestor Estatal y plantea
un aumento de la cotización del 10 al
16% al cargo del empleador esa
iniciativa será definida en última
instancia en el congreso donde hay que
decirlo el oficialismo no tiene mayoría
esto explicó el jefe de estado sobre el
proyecto
la fp en esta reforma se terminan
existirán nuevos gestores de inversión
privados con el objeto exclusivo de
invertir fondos previsionales y además
Existirá una alternativa pública lo que
permitirá promover la competencia con la
entrada de nuevos actores
en esto quiero ser muy claro esto
fortalecerá la libertad de elección de
los afiliados serán ustedes los dueños
de sus ahorros y podrán decidir
libremente entre los gestores de
inversores privados o el inversor
público este nuevo seguro social
reconocerá el trabajo en labores
domésticas y de cuidados labores que en
Chile sabemos recaen principalmente las
mujeres y que actualmente no son
reflejadas en el monto de suspensiones y
después del anuncio de la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos de la subida
de las tasas de interés Hoy es el turno
para el Banco Central de Inglaterra
Mejor dicho ya fue el turno ya sí Y de
todos los bancos serán los próximos días
y más o menos Creo que todos van a ser
lo mismo Claro hoy el Banco Central de
Inglaterra hizo su mayor aumento de
tasas desde 1989 lo hizo un 75 puntos
básicos hasta el 3%. el mismo nivel de
la Fed que guía los pasos de muchos
bancos centrales Aunque la presidenta
del Banco Central europeo Cristina dijo
hoy en un mensaje que no puede
convertirse tampoco en un espejo de su
par estadounidense ahora veamos después
de anunciar la sexta danza consecutiva
de tasas de interés y la cuarta de esa
magnitud de 75 puntos básicos el
presidente de la Powell reconoció que
seguirán haciéndolo porque la batalla
contra la inflación requerirá que el
valor de los préstamos sea todavía más
alto vemos en el gráfico que la
inflación ha venido estando en un nivel
más o menos
estable en los últimos meses esta noche
como a 2% interanual en septiembre y la
tasa de interés sí ha venido subiendo
agresivamente Entonces no sabemos a
ciencia cierta Cuándo es que se va a
empezar a notar sobre la inflación esta
subida de tasas y cómo están los
mercados Soy Dani precisamente Wall
Street abrió con pérdidas pronunciadas
después de esta jornada teñida de rojo
el miércoles a medida que el mercado
digiere este aumento de tasas en Europa
el índice principal de la bolsa de
Londres cae 0,47% después de estos
anuncios Banco Central y caen todavía
más sus pares de la región con la resaca
todavía del discurso de ayer un Power el
que da a entender que el ciclo de
aumentos está muy lejos de terminar y
que nos trae para terminar este bloque
económico como cifra del día alguna vez
ha jugado lotería creo que sí pero no
pero bueno cinco veces en mi vida Bueno
yo no me la Quiero ganar y no la compro
como todos pues mire tiene que ver
entonces la cifra con la lotería de
Powerball que es una de las más grandes
de Estados Unidos y le tengo dos
noticias una buena y una mala señora la
mala es que nadie ganó el enorme
acumulado el miércoles en la noche de
1.200 millones de dólares y la buena es
que se acumula un nuevo premio gordo
1500 millones de dólares que se
sortearán el sábado por la noche se
trata del Tercer premio de lotería más
grande en la historia de este país y le
tengo un dato por si se anima entonces a
jugar vamos a ver las probabilidades de
ganar el premio mayor son de una entre
292,2 millones y el ganador escoger
entre el dinero en efectivo o una
anualidad por 30 años cuál Escoge yo
creo que prefiero la anualidad porque
igual uno dice que es responsable con el
dinero pero se termina oliendo loco con
tanto no y con tasas de interés tan
altas pues es rentable dejar la plática
ahí y recibir rendimientos es así Dani
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica mañana más
economía